my superior project is about making your
program round faster developing the iOS
version of App Inventor is democratized
cross-platform mobile development
routing of drones and communications
constrained environments introduced
economic and political factors into a
machine learning model helping teachers
give better feedback on the students
code this project was a new field for me
it involved computer vision and robotics
we did a clinical trial with three
donors and eleven patients I got the
opportunity to try out one of these
algorithms at the Boston Symphony
Orchestra a couple weeks ago with very
promising results being part of this
program has forced me to better
summarize and communicate ideas working
one-on-one with my supervisor was
extremely useful I want to do mobile
development as a job and so it gave me a
very big full-year project to work on
that it gives you some guidance and an
opportunity to really know how to
communicate your work in a professional
and academic setting it gave me skills
when it came to writing an actual
proposal reading a research paper it
allowed me to like implement a product
and add features to something that
existed which is something that I really
love to do it forces you to take a
problem and kind of break it down into
its fundamental root causes that's a
great skill to have
[Music]